I searched the internet for the coolest
and weirdest table tennis items ever and
today I'll be presenting them to OT and
Ma they will be testing and ranking the
items from best to worst while facing
some really funny challenges let's go
this is so cute it's a face mask okay so
it's sorts of like a ball trampoline you
strap yourself
in try and
play this is great
oh
what who comes up with stuff like this
let's play some
catch ball switch
go Otto has to catch every single ball
that you throw to him I can tell that
Otto used to play in a baseball team the
world's fastest
catch I caught it to the inside one eye
really good item this is going to take
the top spot for now it's quite hard to
beat this item number two bigger than
the fox
is it a replacement for the pongfinity
curtain I see a logo there is that cool
pity barrier like rainproof pongfinity
sleeping bag I think I just take a nap
you also take a nap it's not one SI pit
all what is this turning into you're
going a bit to the side rails here those
actually are the side rails well that
makes more sense you might have to use
some Force what I need my Cape I think
you're on to something guys wow the
first ball y it's a sturdy one they're
so much prettier than these they are not
just for blocking balls what we need
here is the head coach of finish table
tennis is he going to do physically and
high Tempo one
more yes perfect tide steps round wow we
you quite fast OT should be doing these
with me
come well you can use barriers for
physical exercise as well it's a really
good barrier but it's a barrier yeah
it's just a barrier best barriers I've
ever seen but still Fox game still keeps
the number one place I don't even know
what to say about this item 1 2 3 is
this even legal
yeah it's a
bazooka each one of you will have to go
through the obstacle course mik is the
first one to shoot the balls he has
3,000 balls in one
target that was
easy no it's game over after the first
shot I think we'll do better with a pong
FY smash
racket almost got
me you still hit me while Oto is
smashing let me tell you about the best
campaign that we've ever had on our
store when you order two smash Rockets
you will now get a racket case and a
six-pack of balls for free until the end
of February so make sure to take
advantage of the offer before it
ends
[Music]
winner is the Racket and the barrier
place number three the cannon item
number four this is a PO beer oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the challenge is for
you guys pick up the ball you got
started with those a lottery machine
it's also a lottery does it pick the
ball or not I'm not convinced yet you
can adjust it this was the key we were
doing it
wrong yeah what's customizable for your
preferred technique is this version
better than the previous model let's try
this is going to be interesting let's
see which one collects better and faster
go a bit of Head Start for me I
say I'm picking up your balls as well
after thank you last one quite an even
battle I prefer that it's more fun to
use this one has the benefit that it's
easier to empty when you empty it you
can put these and then you empty it oh
that's a game Cher in the beginning I
hated it but now I like it I'd put it on
third place in front of the cannon this
was the most expensive thing let's go
how has this got anything to do with
table tennis table tennis forms said
that this one is the best tool in the
world to cut table tennis rubbers I'm
very skeptical these people who have
written these they must be really bad
with scissors I'm even like surprised if
it even cuts the rubber you'll actually
just get to test like how it works uh
it's just normal paper
now they are changing their
mind and then let's move on to the table
fin robbers real test normal scissors
versus electric scissors a cutting
challenge for table pennis
[Music]
go and stop 29 result really solid of
cutting you can see the years of
experience and go you're doing this for
the very first time grip
change and stop 25 seconds how is the
quality of the cutting it's good this
was your first time if you did this 10
more times it would be Flawless this was
a lot easier than I expected the forums
went wrong this is the best thing for
cutting a tails in rubber should you get
one no no because it's €200 I would
actually put this on the first place if
it wouldn't be for the price number two
it's a bucket list item let's go I'm
guessing it's some kind of soap bubbles
in here and then we dip
it okay this one is a strong one you
have to hit it
hard you have to hit harder that's the
thing oh yeah yeah if you don't touch it
yeah we can play without touching it you
can use like the air flow you divided it
doesn't go past the fox game I'm sorry I
think this takes last place it's a scam
rank number six it seems like item
number seven then what this is what was
talking about flexible stick now now I
see why Emil was so interested about can
you even throw ping pong balls with it
no first the world's longest throw bent
past the scoop you got to fling it is
the dog scoop better than the dog
Cannon oh I can get it there is one more
challenge I have a feeling this is going
to be quite hard quite hard as in quite
impossible it's not too hard it's almost
like it's designed to hold a ball the
ranking for this the fifth spot fifth
please be better this
time oh yeah the concept is the same as
Fox
ball after Fox
ball life just seems great you have to
create music and dance show with this
surprise me
[Applause]
I think I'm going to take the fox toys
away and hide them from you
[Music]
guys we were supposed to portray a very
depressive beginning because we didn't
have the fox hands after ball link
before Cannon position six this is uh
one of the coolest objects that we found
oh the pistol grip this is really cool
do we have a left hand I can still use
this P fin
ties you have to hit completely
different technique very open arm oh
about
backand backand is terrible this shot is
what it's made
for for you it's better for back it's
pretty intuitive the
windmill oh what a chop lock it's very
hard to play with I would wouldn't
recommend it restricting a lot of the
different like spins and so on how would
you rate it before ball sling but after
ball picker yes so pistol rackets you
can get some good spin this is from a
tennis
shop ah yes water
inside yeah placing a lot of trust in
this it broke if that would have come
off on the show not going to be standing
behind the ball after that this is the
funnest
you shouldn't do this with taable tennis
racket a finally I would give this
almost second place of what do you think
definitely definitely second place it's
fun some kind of
machine ooh it looks like a
toilet this is again a dog toy bought
half of the things in the dog shop then
again we've been as entertained as most
dogs okay so you have to return all the
shots I have to
react this is how it work best part of
this was me acting like a dog and the
ranking for Port bot you can you can
practice without the partner three balls
at a time so yeah I put it above ball
sling nothing can be the fox except the
last item yes bring it
on do we need every single piece yes
that's the net you connect the pipes
with this and this looks like a racket
so it's a table it's like a fun little
challenge for the guys enjoy building it
if this works this might beat the fox
game so that's some big words I like the
look of
this it works I like that it's like a
bouncy surface that isn't made for dogs
it's a good solid game I can have it in
the air so that it's easier for for you
guys em became a table himself I'd
rather be the table than the ball life's
great
wisdoms I think this table is
talized I love the concept I'm not too
convinced okay what do you rate this
item between ball sling and click
shooter but was it even better than the
fox no today we have a clear winner
imagine if we ever come up with
something this genius we would own the
world something else that's genius is
the campaign that we have on our web
store right now you get over 25%
discount on the double smash RIT bundle
so here over to pity. store and get
yours okay that's all for today thanks
for watching